And finally, over the weekend, crypto exchange company FTX
crashed and filed for bankruptcy.
Here with more on that is "Late Night" writer
and financial expert Jeff Wright.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you. Thank you, Seth.
FTX is melting down, and I just want to comfort investors
out there by saying I told you so, okay?
Crypto is stupid, and we Black people never trusted it.
-So why do you think Black people never trusted it?
-Well, first of all, we are naturally skeptical
about everything a white man tells us.
For example, when you hired me to be on the show,
I thought you were playin'.
I'm so paranoid, I still don't know if I really work here.
Matter of fact, I never unpacked.
My bags are right there.
-That's ridiculous, Jeff.
You've been here for two years now.
-Ah, interesting. You're really keeping track, aren't you?
[ Laughter ]
Anyways, we don't trust crypto because it's inconsistent.
Black people only recently started getting money
and building wealth in our own communities,
and what did white people do?
Went and changed what money was.
Just created a whole new currency!
You can't create a new game when we just learned this one!
It's like the makers of Uno coming out with the game Dos.
[ Laughter ]
Why would you do that
when some people don't know how to play Uno the right way?
-You can't put a Draw 4 on a Draw 4!
-Yes, you can, Seth!
-No! -That's how you play!
-No, you cannot do that!
[ Laughter ]
Anyway, as a financial expert, what do you suggest other
crypto exchange companies do to avoid their own demise?
-Well, first, we got to change the name of crypto.
You can't say, "We made this new money,
and it's totally safe and easy to understand,"
and then call it "crypto."
I mean, listen to it. Crypto.
That sounds less like money
and more like the new dance craze in Compton, California.
I could just picture someone going, "Hey,
show your auntie that new crypto dance y'all been doing."
Second, you've got to make the currencies themselves
sound less crazy.
Back in the day, you invested
in things like Apple, Google, Microsoft.
Nowadays, you got people investing in Ethereum.
What the hell is an Ethereum?
First time I heard of it,
I thought it was a new house in "Harry Potter."
Someone asked me, "Hey, man, you on that Ethereum?"
I was like, "No. The BuzzFeed quiz said I was a Slytherin."
[ Laughter ]
-Now, Jeff, what would you tell everyday investors
who are, you know, looking to make a profit?
-Well, first, I would tell them listen to Black people, okay?
We've never been wrong.
And even when we were, we would never admit it.
Secondly, if you don't know how to spell it or where it's from,
don't buy it, okay?
Lastly, but more importantly,
stop listening to your dumb-ass friends, okay?
Just because they bought a little bit of Bitcoin
does not mean they're a Wall Street day trader.
My friend Sean bought a little bit of Bitcoin.
Now he wears a business suit and a earpiece.
He started using words like "diversify" and "portfolio."
You still work at Subway, Sean!
[ Laughter ]
-Give it up for our financial expert, Jeff Wright, everybody!